ge de sitôt c'est l'un des aliments
phare de ce salon de produits
monastiques fabriqués par des moines
cisterciens en côte d'or il est réputé
pour son goût crémeux sarah un fromage à
ceyrat c
est au milieu des fromages bourguignon
je trouve qu'ils se démarquent un petit
peu
il est moins fort qu'un
jeu c'est plus de certains autres qui
sont un peu trop puissant pour moi dans
le cellier de l'abbaye de noirlac les
500 gourmandises sucrées ou salées
exposés viennent d'une trentaine de
monastère situé en france ou à
l'étranger c'est la sixième édition on a
de plus en plus de monde chaque année le
bouche à oreille fonctionne très bien il
faut savoir que les moines et les
moniales fabrique vraiment pour subvenir
à leurs besoins et non pas pour le
profit donc on essaye de mettre ceci en
avant ses produits ont une authenticité
de matières premières
les gens cherchent ça je pense
aujourd'hui nous aussi donc on essaye
vraiment de rendre populaire en fait ces
produits autres produits emblématiques
du salon la liqueur de l'abbaye de la
grande chartreuse un élixir à base de
130 plants et une recette secrète que
l'on se transmet de père en père depuis
le 17e siècle alors forcément ça
décoiffe il est clair que je trouve
un bol un moins costauds du jus de pomme
de la confiture ou du savon tous
fabriqués dans le respect des traditions
monacale on a ce label maintenant
monastique qui existe qui met les
produits vraiment
fabriquer dans les abbayes en avant donc
c'est un label qui existe depuis 20 ans
ou même une partie des fonds récoltés
servira à financer les futurs événements
de l'abbaye de noirlac classé monument
historique
l'édifice est aujourd'hui un centre
culturel de rencontre